bonjour à toutes et à tous ceux c'est
paléo news l'émission qui fait des news
avec du vieux alors dans l'actualité de
la semaine vous n'avez certainement pas
pu rater cette cette annonce de la
découverte de trilobites en file
indienne ou du moins la première
description officielle de trilobites en
file indienne non pas qu'on n'en avaient
pas trouvé avant mais c'est la première
fois qu'on les décrivent vraiment
trilobites en file indienne donc qu'ils
soutiendraient qu'il existerait qu'il a
existé déjà un comportement social vieux
de 480 millions d'années alors c'est une
c'est une nouvelle qui a atteint le vrai
le web français et pour cause elle a été
publiée par des chercheurs qui sont
essentiellement français avec des co
auteurs suisses et marocains donc ce que
vous pouvez voir dans la liste ici donc
vous avez ici le col et co auteur qui
viennent de l'université de cadi ayyad à
marrakech et les co auteurs qui viennent
aussi de suisse donc de lausanne mais la
plupart des auteurs sont français soit
de poitiers soit de lyon soit de brest
donc c'est donc cette nouvelle a atteint
le web français assez facilement
puisqu'elle est l est du coup et puisque
c'est l'article en lui même a été écrits
par des auteurs français et a été
publiée dans la revue scientifique
report ce qui est une revue open access
donc c'est pareil ça va être pas mal
pour la diffusion des nouvelles d'avoir
une revue open access c'est à dire une
revue qui nous on n'a pas besoin de
payer pour y accéder il ya que les
auteurs qui payent pour pouvoir publier
bon ça c'est un autre problème mais
voilà et donc c'est une c'est un une
annonce qui a été accueillie avec pas
mal de scepticisme en fait à la suite de
sa publication en fin du moins de à la
suite de la publication des communiqués
de presse et notamment parce que
beaucoup de gens ont remarqué très
rapidement que en fait ces lignes de
trilobites donc ces files indiennes de
trilobites qui suggère un comportement
social
ça fait penser par exemple aux chenilles
processionnaires ou bien à certaines
espèces de homard aussi qui s'assemblent
ou de langoustines je ne sais plus il ya
des crustacés qui font ça qui
s'assemblent pour migrer en file
indienne comme ça donc c'est vrai que ça
ressemble à un comportement qu'on voit
chez les espèces modernes
oui mais il y en a qui ont
judicieusement remarquer que bas il n'y
avait pas que que c'était pas des
assemblages mono spécifique voilà il ya
des il ya des parasites dans le signal
j'ai envie de dire avec ses petits ces
petits trilobites que vous voyez là en
violet dans les files indiennes de
trilobites orange et qui n'appartiennent
pas au même espèce et donc ça c'est ça
rapidement évidemment fait penser qu'il
y avait qu il pourrait y avoir un
problème en fait finalement avec cet
article alors du coup on va le
décortiquer un petit peu histoire de
voir ce qu'il en est et alors déjà le
premier truc par rapport à la non ce qui
a été fait
enfin l' annonce de presque que vous
avez pu voir par rapport à l'article
original
c'est l'emploi du mot comportement
social donc vous voyez là ici c'est dans
sciences et avenir donc vous voyez qu'il
titre clairement un comportement social
vieux de 480 millions d'années ça me
semble important de nuancer
l'utilisation du mot social dans un
groupe comme les arthropodes où les
comportements sociaux peuvent aller de
extrêmement solitaire solitaire au point
que même quand tu ta couple tutu la
personne avec qui tu ta couple penser
aux montres religieuse ou aux araignées
par exemple à des comportements qu'on
qualifie 2e sociaux c'est-à-dire les
fourmis les abeilles acquis dont
l'organisation fait littéralement passé
nos petites sociétés de primates pour
des gougnafiers mal organisés quoi donc
il faut bien relativiser l'utilisation
du terme social quand on parle
d'arthropodes qu'est-ce qu'on pas de
quoi on parle quand on parle de
comportement social et là en
l'occurrence on parle juste d'espèces
fin d'une espèce qui était possiblement
solitaire et qui se réunissent et
uniquement peut-être pour la migration
ou la reproduction ou les deux puisque
ce sont ce sont à peu près les deux
raisons pour lesquelles les chenilles
processionnaires et les
et les crustacés fonds ont ce genre de
comportement de se mettre en file
indienne c'est la migration ou la
reproduction donc donc voilà et pour le
coup l'article et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut toujours se référer à l'article
original ne parle pas de comportement
social dans son titre mais bien de
comportement collectif et ça c'est
important
donc c'est un comportement collectif qui
n'appliquent pas que l'espèce elle-même
a un comportement social le reste du
temps est alors après que nous dit cet
article et mérite t-il tout ce
scepticisme et bien déjà on peut
s'avancer à la seconde page de l'article
seconde page de cet article où on nous
parle un peu vain de ce qu'on a donc
laissons les résultats c'est la
description de ce spécimen de ces
spécimens puisqu'il n'y en a pas qu'un
ils en ont plusieurs
et alors ce qu'il voit c'est déjà le
nombre de spécimens peuvent varier de 3
à 22 donc on est définitivement pas sur
un comportement qui est d'une très
grande constance du moins si on admet
que tout est préservée à chaque fois
peut-être qu'il ya certains morceaux qui
ont été enlevés et que du coup il y
avait peut-être des lignes toutes les
lignes avait plus de dix individus mais
que certaines ont été endommagées mais
en tout cas voilà il ya il ya quand même
une certaine variabilité dans ce
comportement si comportement il y a que
tout est extrêmement bien préservés
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de spécimens
désarticulé et surtout quelque chose qui
semble important à préciser c'est que
tous les spécimens sont des adultes ce
qui est écrit ici
voilà donc il n'y a pas d'exclusive il
n'y a pas d'exode vie ça veut dire qu'il
ya pas de ya pas de mu donc ce ne sont
pas des carcasses ce sont des animaux
qui était bien vivant et ce sont des
animaux qui sont morts à l'âge adulte
comme il est écrit ici
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
qu'ils sont à leur stade
aulas pis avec six segments développer
ce qui est le maximum pour cette espèce
c'est ce qui est écrit la voilà six
thoracique segmente il n'ya pas ya pas d
xvi pardon et donc c'est pas des c'est
pas juste des musées pas des coquilles
de mu qu'on voit ce sont bien des
animaux qui sont qui sont morts et il
s'agit de
tous individus adultes à leur stade
aulas pis avec leur six segments
thoracique bien développé donc ça ça
quand même si on devait aller du côté de
l'hypothèse d'une migration d'individus
à des fins de reproduction
on serait quand même bien partie là il
ya quand même il ya quand même quelque
chose il faut quand même expliquer
pourquoi
si ce n'est pas un comportement typique
typiquement lié à la reproduction
pourquoi on ne trouve aucun individu
immature peut-être un vrai d'un billet
de préservation mais en tout cas la
préservation le fait que tous les
individus soient préservés qu'ils aient
eu quasiment aucun dérangement du site
de fossilisation n'indique fin ne n'est
pas vraiment en faveur d'un billet de
d'un billet taphonomie quoi il n'ya pas
deux il n'y a pas l'air d'y avoir de
billet de fossilisation donc donc on est
plutôt bien parti en fait pour un pur
pour cette interprétation d'un
comportement de migration peut être lié
à la reproduction et surtout ce qu'on
voit dans le paragraphe suivant la
discussion c'est une vie il ya une
discussion très très longue
à propos des conditions de fossilisation
donc in situ préservation les conditions
de fossilisation qui indique que cet
assemblage en ligne en fait ne sont pas
dues à des ne sont pas dus en fait un
relief
parce qu'évidemment le meilleur moyen
d'accumuler en ligne des fossiles c'est
qu'il y ait juste une petite vallée
voilà et vous imaginez bien que les
fossiles vont spontanément par gravité
allez s'accumuler dans la petite vallée
bon il n'y a pas de choses comme ça au
niveau des traces de courant on pourrait
on pourrait il peut faire l'hypothèse
que c'est le courant qui a orienté les
fossiles de cette façon c'est pareil les
traces de courant sont pas cohérentes
avec cette interprétation donc a priori
il n'ya pas c'est pas une raison
mécanique qui a poussé les fossiles à
être fossilisés comme ça donc encore une
fois là
on est on est plutôt en faveur de d'une
hypothèse qui impliquerait un
comportement social
enfin un comportement collectif
justement je tombe dans mon propre piège
donc au final qu'est ce que c'est le
problème c'est vraiment cesser ces
individus qui ne sont pas des voeux de
la même espèce que tout le reste en fait
le vrai problème c'est ça et le fait est
que ce n'est pas un ce n'est pas un
petit détail il ya quand même 57% des
spécimens de ces deux de ces plaques sur
lesquels sont préservés les lignes de
les assemblages en ligne de de
trilobites il y en a quand même 57% donc
qui ne sont pas dus qui n'appartiennent
pas au genre en pics donc et après vous
avez évidemment toute une variété
d'autres trilobites dont les dont les
noms sont listés ici et donc mais de ses
57 % il y en a que quatre qui font
partie d'un assemblage en ligne
donc il ya 57 % des espèces 57% des
assemblages voilà des fossiles
d'assemblage contiennent des fossiles
d'autres espèces mais seulement 4,4
spécimens par 4% seulement quatre
spécimens contiennent contiennent un
trilobites qui est en ligne avec les en
pics avec les eaux avec les trilobites
qui sont en ligne
donc ça reste quelque chose d'assez
marginal mais évidemment c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même suffisamment
marc gym marginal pour pour soulever une
certaine un certain scepticisme
pourquoi parce que les le diable est
dans les détails j'ai envie de dire est
que considérer ça comme un petit détail
1 à côté on s'est peut-être là que se
trouve l'erreur si erreur il y a alors
mon avis à moi c'est que ben évidemment
étant moi même intéressé par les
paléopathologie aider paléopathologie
c'est typiquement c'est comme c'est
historiquement ça marche comme la
médecine c'est à dire que quand ça
marche on sait pas comment ça marche
c'est quand ça marche pas qu'on voit
comment ça marche
voilà donc hélas c'est typiquement ça
s'est il faut accorder de l'importance
au cas où ça marche pas et ses petits
ces petits intrus là c'est typiquement
des cas comme ça marche pas c'est à dire
que si vous avez effectivement
comportement collectif de la part d'une
espèce il devrait pas y avoir d'autres
espèces qui s'inclut dans le lot sinon
c'est plus un comportement collectif
d'une espèce ça devient un comportement
symbiotique et alors là on part dans un
tout autre nid
deux théories quoi donc donc je pense
mon avis à moi c'est que je pense qu'en
fait la théorie du comportement
collectif est la meilleure parce qu'on
n'a pas mieux
il ya vraiment rien qui peut expliquer
comment des trilobites par se retrouver
en ligne comme ça et tous orientés dans
la même direction
si c'est pas le courant et si c'est pas
un palais au relief quoi il n'y a pas
grand chose qui peut expliquer ça et
surtout qu'apparemment ils ont des ils
ont ça au maroc mais apparemment il
retrouve sa aussi en chine et en
montagne noire en france 2 va pas de
l'ordovicien montagne noire c'est de
l'ordovicien mais en chine c'est du
cambrien mais voilà il retrouve des
choses assez similaires avec d'autres
d'autres taxons d'arthropodes à d'autres
endroits donc voilà j'ai envie de dire
comportement collectif oui pour
l'instant parce qu'on voit pas trop
comment expliquer ça autrement mais la
présence de ces petits trucs là de ces
de ces petits intrus elle et elle n'est
pas négligeable et ne devrait pas être
négligée et évidemment la question c'est
est ce qu'on voit ça chez les ch et les
arthropodes moderne avec les
comportements similaires
ben non les comportements modèle les
arthropodes moderne qui se baladent à la
queue leu leu n'ont jamais été observées
en train d'accueillir des potes d'une
autre espèce dans dans leur petite file
indienne quoi donc
donc voilà ils font pas la chenille ils
font pas la chenille avec d'autres
espèces chenilles arthropodes vous avez
compris le le jeu de mots donc donc quoi
en penser et ben c'est très intéressant
ça fait de très beau ça fait de très
belles images et je pense que c'est pour
ça que ça a eu un succès médiatique
aussi aussi prononcée parce que en soit
finalement c'est un comportement qui
était déjà connue chez les arthropodes
et que qui est retrouvée chez des
arthropodes suffisamment distant
phylogénétiquement pour qu'on puisse
s'imaginer qu'il est originaire du
paléozoïque son comportement donc donc
en soi c'est une preuve de quelque chose
dont on se doutait déjà mais ça fait des
jolies photos donc sa une
une belle couverture médiatique ça
apporte du coude et encore une fois
comme la plupart des découvertes ça
apporte beaucoup de questions plus que
ça n'en répond est l'une des luttes des
grosses contributions à mon avis ça va
être d'enfin essayer de comprendre 12 à
quoi servait ses antennes la face et
petite projection
parce que c'est c'est quand même pas
anodin que ce comportement soit
retrouvée chez un trilobites chez qui on
retrouve ces projections et ça ça à mon
avis ça va être la grosse contribution
de ce travail si évidemment j'espère
qu'ils continuent à travailler dessus et
qu'il va y avoir plus de publier à ce
propos là mais vous voyez que l'article
et déjà l'on en soit mais voilà ce qui à
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est que en
fait il aurait pu se servir de leurs
extrémités et de leurs antennes puisque
les trilobites avait des antennes afin
de maintenir cette cohésion de ce
comportement grégaire on va dire afin de
maintenir la ligne
il aurait pu avoir des récepteurs au
bout de ces deux de leurs indices et ça
donc ça expliquerait aussi pourquoi on
voit se développer des appendices chez
les trilobites au moins en partie
donc ça c'est une piste qu'ils lancent
dans l'article et à mon avis c'est une
piste qui méritera d'être d'être suivis
parce que c'est vraiment là selon moi
c'est la grosse contribution de cet
article c'est vraiment d'arriver à
comprendre enfin les ajustements les
signaux que pouvaient s'envoyer les
trilobites qu'il soit chimiques qu'ils
soient mécaniques etc et commencé comme
ans l'utilisation de ces signaux a fini
par influencer l'évolution de leur
morphologie et notamment de ses
structures si bizarre et si particulière
qu'on retrouve chez les trilobites
metref d'invertébrés la semaine dernière
c'était le 79e meeting annuel de la
société de weert et de paléontologie des
vertébrés donc society of vertebrate
paleontology et pour faire court à
partir de maintenant je vais l'appeler s
veepee parce que c'est vraiment trop
long à dire à chaque fois 79e meeting de
de la society of vertebrate paleontology
donc ça s'est déroulé à brisbane en
australie et j'ai eu la chance d'y être
et du coup ça va être l'occasion pour
moi bien de vous présenter un peu ce que
c'est qu'un meeting de paléontologie des
vertébrés parce que quand même il ya
beaucoup de deux il ya beaucoup de
bullshit qui sont racontées à propos de
ce genre de meeting
les premiers et un le premier étant que
c'est là que se déroule le grand complot
darwinien 1
voilà donc une bande de une bande de
mecs habillés en noir réunis dans une
salle sombre en train de comploter pour
faire continuer à croire au monde que
les espèces évoluent
ben non c'est pas du tout ça évidemment
donc le live hippie donc c'est le plus
grand meeting de paléontologie des
vertébrés au monde alors à brisbane
c'était une petite session puisqu'il n'y
avait que 1200 personnes
bon normalement ils sont organisés en
amérique du nord et alors là quand c'est
en amérique du nord
on frise les 2000 participants donc là
c'était plutôt une petite session mais
c'était pour le mieux puisque ça
augmentait la diversité du nombre de
choses présentées c'est à dire que pour
une fois ce n'était pas 90% du dinosaure
nord-américain quoi tout ça pour eux
c'est on a les mêmes biais que tout le
monde je veux dire quand on quand on
fait un meeting en amérique du nord
on a une sur représentation de
chercheurs d'amérique du nord donc là
pour une fois avoir les avoir un meeting
autres parcs en amérique du nord c'était
que le troisième c'est le sait que le
troisième meeting qui est organisée
ailleurs qu'en amérique du nord
donc pour la sbp y donc c'est pas anodin
eh ben ça augmente pas mal la diversité
et du coup on a eu du synappci d' donc
moi même ainsi que pas mal de mes
collègues on a eu beaucoup de mammifères
et on a eu aussi même du poisson
donc c'est pour vous dire à quel point
c'était diversifiée et donc c'est le
plus grand meeting du monde
en termes de paléontologie des vertébrés
mais il faut pas voir ça comme je disais
comme un rassemblement de gens
extrêmement sérieux et est extrêmement
pompeux en fait faut faut plutôt voir ça
en fait comme la comicon du palais aux
geeks quoi c'est une convention si vous
êtes déjà allé à une convention je vous
montre des images en ce moment voilà
c'est réellement comme une convention de
geek donc les gens je crois c'est la
première fois que je vois aussi peu de
gens présentés avec une chemise
les gens n'ont même pas pris la peine de
présent de faire leur présentation en
chemise afin de présenter leur travail
leurs recherches
je veux dire en chemise donc c'est
vraiment comme une convention vous avez
un centre d'exposition où les gens
présentent bien s'ils ont des choses à
vendre
ils les vendent donc vous pouvez voir
qu'il ya déjà des modèles pour les
musées par exemple qui peuvent être
achetés par des musées vous pouvez
acheter des publications évidemment et
vous avez les étudiants ainsi que les
chercheurs qui présentent leurs
recherches soit par poster donc là c'est
là où ce que je vous montre en ce moment
c'est là où il y avait la cession de
poster donc tous les jours il ya une
nouvelle session de poster donc les gens
affichent leurs posters et puis bon on
prend une bière ou un café puis on
discute autour du poster voilà on se
fait des potes on rencontre les
collègues souvent souvent ce qui arrive
c'est qu'on collabore avec des gens mais
on n'a jamais vu leur tête voilà on
collabore par email interposés ou par
articles interposés et on n'a jamais vu
leur tête donc c'est le moment de voir
leur tête c'est le moment de mettre des
noms sur les visages quoi parce que
contrairement encore une fois est-ce que
l'idée du complot darwinien sous-entend
évidemment on ne se connaît pas tous
alors le
le meeting de nice veepee c'est
l'occasion de faire des rencontres et de
se réunir avec les autres darwiniste
pour discuter du grand complot darwinien
des licornes et aussi des
extraterrestres
c'est vraiment le festival du grand
complot mondial à côté de la licorne de
l'extraterrestre vous avez la preuve que
les dinosaures et d'hommes ont coexisté
voilà c'est magnifique tricératops avec
une scène et surtout la terre plate pas
n'ont justement pas l'internet la terre
est ronde
ce ferry centre dépend donc mais c'est
surtout l'occasion de rencontrer des
gens influents dans le milieu de se
faire des relations comme on dit de
faire du networking
pourquoi tout simplement parce que le
financement c'est une denrée rare et
évidemment c'est les gens influents qui
ont des financements donc on est tous un
peu à la recherche de financement de
pouvoir se greffer éventuellement à des
projets qui sont qui sont bien financés
et puis c'est évidemment l'occasion
aussi de discuter collaboration avec
avec des gens avec qui on a des points
communs ou pas d'ailleurs
ça peut être l'occasion de lancer des
nouveaux projets de recherche aussi et
puis c'est l'occasion de placer ses
connaissances ses étudiants voilà si
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui à la
recherche d'un post doc que vous savez
que vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui
cherche à employer un post doc et ben
voilà c'est le moment de plat son nom si
vous même vous êtes à la recherche d'un
app aux docks aussi ça peut généralement
là que vous allez parce que c'est le
mans où vous pouvez justement rencontrer
le plus de personnes dans votre domaine
donc c'est vraiment ça le
c'est vraiment ça le coeur de l'idée en
fait de ses meetings c'est pas c'est pas
de ces pas de comploter c'est pas 2
c'est pas de se mettre d'accord c'est
vrai de se mettre d'accord sur quelle
est la voie à suivre pour le futur c'est
vraiment de se rencontrer et ça se fait
dans une ambiance qui est qui et bon
enfant voire même très très bon enfant 1
on a tous au moins un t-shirt jurassic
park à un moment et évidemment il ya du
cosplay il ya du cosplay et là je vous
montre les images en ce moment il ya des
gens qui se font plaisir aux niveaux
déguisements donc donc voilà c'est faux
c'est très bon enfant
c'est là pour le coup c'était d'autant
plus bon enfant que c'était loin
d'amérique du nord c'est à dire loin de
l'endroit où ils le font habituellement
donc pour le coup les gens étaient
vraiment beaucoup plus en mode vacances
qui ne le sont habituellement mais
évidemment c'est aussi du sérieux il ya
aussi des choses sérieuses qui se passe
à la hayes lippi et notamment à
découvrir les dernières grandes
découvertes en avant première et ça
c'est ça c'est cool de voir les
présentations de travaux qui sont en
cours et non pas attendre qu'ils soient
publiés
donc en avant première par exemple on a
eu cette cette nouvelle technique qui
consiste à utiliser la dégradation des
protéines dans les ossements de
dinosaures et d'autres choses d'ailleurs
dans les ossements de vertébrés en
général donc présenté par dr weill man
cette technique en ni plus ni moins que
de que de dédier les protéines qui ont
été repliés rabougri par la
fossilisation donc vous avez
certainement remarqué en fait que
beaucoup de dos mans fossiles étaient
noirs ils sont noirs pourquoi parce
qu'ils contiennent du carbone et ce
carbone d'où il vient il vient des
protéines et notamment du collagène donc
en fait ce carbone
il est encore à l'état de carbone ce
sont des protéines qui ont été comme je
disais rabougri par la fossilisation
elles ont morflé en pression et en
température et en fait ce que le dr
waldman
et le docteur briggs qui travaille avec
elle puisque d'ailleurs je sais même pas
si elle est docteur en fait je crois
qu'elle est étudiante elle est encore en
thèse en fait peut-être qu'elle est même
pas docteur mais bref
donc elle est le docteur briggs qui lui
est spécialisée sur la préservation la
guerre stadt donc les très très belle
préservation en fait ils ont mis au
point un procédé qui permet de
reconstituer que commet une protéine
s'est dégradée donc c'est à dire que en
fonction de l'état de la protéine au
moment où on la regarde aujourd'hui il
arrive à reconstituer comment cette
protéine s'est dégradée et ça ça a deux
conséquences majeures
ça veut dire qu'ils sont capable
justement comme je disais de déplier la
protéine rabougris et de la reconstituer
au moins théoriquement
c'est à dire qu'ils arrivent à accéder
aux séquences de protéines telle qu'elle
était avant de se rabougrir et
apparemment donc ce qu'ils disaient dans
leur présentation
c'est qu'ils avaient un taux de succès
de 60% alors battu vous savez quoi je
vais consulter donc le livre d'abstract
et je vais vous chercher ça en direct
voilà donc vehlmann on va chercher donc
voyez que la donc c'était genre le
premier jour en plus qu'ils ont présenté
ça donc c'était vraiment le gros truc
vous voyez que ça a pris plusieurs
plusieurs présentations et vous voyez
donc ici la une de leur présentation
alors est ce que j'arrive à le retrouver
voilà par exemple ils ont pu tester le
grâce à ça ils ont pu tester les
affinités
donc les affinités les relais les
relations de parenté duty lindstrom donc
le monstre de tully cette espèce de de
blob
voilà c'est un fossile qu'on retrouve
dans le carbonifère d'amérique du nord
c'est un ça ressemble à rien ça une
espèce de bras articulés sur la tête ça
une espèce de queue mais on n'avait
aucune idée de ce que c'était au point
que certains disaient que c'était un
vertébré donc à poissons et d'autres
disaient que c'était savait rien à voir
avec un vertébré que c'était un
mollusque et ben du coup ils ont pu
regarder les protéines de ce tu
lindstrom
ils ont pu les déplier et grâce à leur
nouvelle technique ils ont pu analyser
la séquence protéique qui l'ont extraite
la comparer aux vertébrés moderne et on
conclure qu'il s'agissait plus
probablement d'invertébrés donc d'un
poisson et ça c'est quand même cool ça
c'est quand même bien cool parce que les
mecs mine de rien ils viennent de
résoudre un problème qui dure depuis
plus presque cent ans quasiment bon qui
est alors évidemment la nato des
anatomistes avait déjà proposé ça il ya
quelques années il me semble il ya deux
trois ans mais maintenant voilà
maintenant qu'on a des données
moléculaires qui qui vont dans ce sens
là on a vraiment on peut avoir une
confiance il ya une cohérence du signal
déjà qui permet d'avoir confiance en ses
résultats voilà et le signal
phylogénétique retenue dans l'est dans
les tissus mous des fossiles et eux ils
l'ont appliqué à la phylogénie des
tortues voilà donc gros gros débat sur
la position phylogénétique des tortues
sont elles proche des archosaures ou d
autres reptiles ou à la base des
reptiles voilà
à la base des reptiles donc ce qui
serait en cohérence avec leurs crânes
apside mais maintenant on sait que ce
sont des choses qui ont évolué de façon
convergente assez souvent au final est
bien heureux ils ont du coup regardez
les séquences protéique de pas mal de
bestioles de pas mal de vertébrés dont
les dons des tortues fossilisés et en
fait ils ont déjà ils ont réussi à
confirmer que de près de 60 % des
espèces fossiles qu'ils ont pu regarder
retrouver leur position phylogénétique
original donc enfin leur position
phylogénétique telle qu'on pense qu'elle
est à partir de la morphologie donc ça
veut dire que leur leur technique
elle marche à 60% c'est pas dégueulasse
ça peut ça peut s'améliorer mais bon
comme j'ai dit si elle est vraiment en
thèse comme je crois me souvenir calais
il ya encore du temps pour que la
technique s'améliore la technique est
pas encore publié enfin la technique je
crois et publié mais pas encore les
résultats donc
donc il ya encore beaucoup de place pour
que ça s'améliore en fait 1 1 là c'est
vrai que 60% c'est à peine plus que
qu'une chance sur deux mais bon dans un
arbre phylogénétique il n'existe pas une
chance sur deux de trouver sa bonne
place la chance de trouver sa bonne
place dans l'arbre phylogénétique il y
en a qu'une
surtout sur tout le reste des branches
de l'arbre phylogénétique donc déjà une
chance sur deux c'est vachement bien
une chance sur de tomber juste c'est
vachement bien et ils sont un petit peu
plus au dessus ils sont à 60%
donc voila et donc avec ça ils arrivent
à soutenir la position phylogénétique
des tortues parmi en groupe frère dé
archosaures du coup donc le clad des
arcs et l'odeur est la dernière chose
la dernière chose dont ils ont aussi
étudié des oeufs des oeufs des eaux
fossiles ise est ce que est ce que je
vais arriver à le retrouver
donc oui là c'est le métabolique wright
voilà donc c'est encore un talk de la
même personne donc jasmin avait man et
qui a fait encore une fois parler cette
fois des métabolique wright alors les
taux métabolique c'est la question clé
en fait deux c'est la question clé de
landau thermie alors avant que j'attaque
landau termine je vois que le chiffre de
60% c'est là qu'il est voilà donc ils
ont retrouvé une phylogénie précise à
curie de phylogénie dans 60 % des cas
voilà c'est ici que le chiffre se trouve
page page page page 218 voix là et donc
ils ont aussi reconstituer les taux
métabolique alors les taux métabolique
qu'est ce que c'est c2c le métabolisme
de base quoi c'est là est ce qu'on a le
sang chaud ou à sang froid parce que ce
qu'ils ont découvert en fait en faisant
leur petit leur petit des leurs petits
des pliages de protéines sur sur leurs
protéines fossile va c'est qu'en fait le
pliage la façon dont les protéines se
rabougrissent est fondamentalement
différente entre ceux entre les
vertébrés à sang chaud et les vertébrés
à sang froid les vertébrés à son show
ayant des protéines enfin ayant une
dégradation de leurs protéines qui est
beaucoup plus rapide et qui donc prend
un chemin différent
finalement que la dégradation des
protéines chez les vertébrés à sang
froid et du coup bah ça leur a permis de
reconstituer des taux protéique chez
quelques espèces par les taux
métabolique chez quelques espèces donc
en l'occurrence si j'arrive à retrouver
exactement où ils sont où ils en parlent
voilà c'est ici donc les dinosaures
bipèdes et volant alors ont le sang
chaud d'après eux les dinosaures bipèdes
et volant donc je crois me souvenir
qu'ils avaient inclus
il avait inclus à lauzon russe et
velociraptor ils ont retrouvé les
ptérosaures à sang chaud donc ce qui est
plutôt cohérent avec le fait qu'ils
avaient des plumes en fin dé protoplumes
et oui je
je m'en remettrai pas à prononcer le
terme pompeux que je sais plus qui a
inventé pour parler de protoplumes chez
les ptérosaures cd protoplumes voilà
c'est de la plume filamenteuses ils ont
retrouvé un métabolisme à sang chaud
chez les plésiosaures chez des
archosaures bipèdes donc je suppose
qu'il parle de certains archosaures du
trias genre très proche de park et ria
je suppose et les mammifères
bon évidemment les mammifères c'est pas
une surprise donc bon il retrouve les
oiseaux et les mammifères à sang chaud
donc ça c'est plutôt normal et ça veut
dire que leur technique marche
relativement bien et là où c'est
intéressant du coup c'est qu'il retrouve
les synappci de base eau comme étant
endothermique et comme on parle de gens
qui travaillent en amérique du nord et
qui ont voulu faire une étude
préliminaire
quand il parle de cynapsys bazzo c'est
très certainement dit métro dont 10
métro dont à sang froid du coup c'est
pas non plus une grosse grosse surprise
quoi mais mais du coup ça donne envie de
savoir ce qu'ils vont trouver pour des
synapses it + dérivés comme les
thérapies d'où les signaux donc quoi et
évidemment ils retrouvent les l'epide
aux orres donc les lézards comme des
ectothermes donc ce qui encore une fois
confirme que lors que leur système
marche relativement bien donc du moins
fonctionne de façon cohérente avec leur
interprétation
donc c'est plutôt cool c'est plutôt cool
et j'ai hâte de voir ce que ça va donner
une fois que ce sera fini et publié
parce que parce que vraiment là ça
pourrait ouvrir une toute nouvelle porte
à la paléontologie quoi si je veux dire
vous imaginer la quantité de fossiles
d'ossements qui sont retrouvés noirâtre
à cause de la matière organique mais et
ben vous imaginez qu'en fait tous ces
fossiles noirâtre ils vont pouvoir être
exploitées en utilisant cette technique
donc voilà c'est ça ouvre des portes
mais à l'infini quoi donc c'est très
excitant comme genre de nouvelles
découvertes qu'on fait pendant ce
justement ces meetings comme pendant ces
rencontres ces conférences évidemment
c'est aussi le moment donc ces
rencontres de faire
de voir se dérouler devant nos yeux les
grands débats de notre de notre
discipline est l'un des plus grands
débats qui a lieu en ce moment dans
notre discipline c'est le débat sur les
ornithologues l'ida donc on avait fait
toute une vidéo là dessus sur les
ornithos élida donc l'ornitho celi da
pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi
pour les trois au fond qui continue à
regarder cette vidéo mais qui ne savent
pas ce que sont les ornithos et dida je
sais qu'ils doivent être que 3 et bien
les donc la classification des
dinosaures ça a toujours été d'un côté
les ornithischiens et de l'autre les
souris ce qui est donc les
ornithischiens qui ont un bassin
d'oiseaux les souris ce qu'un qui ont un
bassin de reptiles les ornithischiens
ces lézards bigorre laisse aux risques
yacé les sauropodes donc long cou petite
tête et les théropodes c'est à dire
globalement les carnivores et je sais
retient ton commentaire il n'y a pas que
des carnivores chez les théropodes je
suis au courant
il ya des colibris aussi voilà donc mais
claude legault grosso modo c'est comme
ça que ça se passait jusqu'à ce que un
pavé dans la mare soient jetés en 2010
est donc baron est talent qui ont
découvert enfin qui ont proposé avec à
l'appui une toute nouvelle matrice
phylogénétique est une toute nouvelle
analyse phylogénétique qui ont proposé
que en fait on s'est plantés depuis le
début c'est la vraie phylogénie des
dinosaures c'est d'un côté les
sauropodes et de l'autre côté les
théropodes et les ornithischiens qui
forment donc les ornithos élida donc on
aurait d'un côté les sauropodes et de
l'autre les ornithos élida enfin
sauropodomorphes du coup parce qu'il n'y
aurait pas que des sauropodes dans le
nom dans le lot il y aurait aussi
d'autres d'autres trucs genre et aux
raptor et des choses comme ça donc
et voilà où on en était et donc déjà
donc déjà ça va pas fait l'unanimité
évidemment pas ce que vous imaginez bien
qu'une grosse annonce comme ça plus on a
de plus l'annoncé grosses et plus les
preuves doivent être puissante et en
l'occurrence les ya des spécialistes
comme max longueur qui ont très très
vite détecté qu'il y avait des erreurs
dans la halle analyse phylogénétique
réalisé par baron et qui avait publié
une contre publication peu de temps
après ce à quoi ce à quoi baron étals
ont de nouveau répondu à longueur et al
en leur disant que bon on a corrigé les
erreurs et on retrouve toujours les
ornithos et l'ida et du coup ben yahia
maintenant depuis 2010 est il ya un
champ de recherche sur les ornithos et
dida où les gens essayent de reproduire
les résultats de baron avec ou sans
succès des fois et du coup là il ya eu
le dernier la dernière recherche qui a
eu là dessus et je pense que je peux
arriver à le retrouver en tapant
ornithos élida dans la barre de
recherche
et ben non c'est parce que j'ai mal
orthographié ornithos élida les aléas du
direct
voilà les ornithos élida donc par kane
donc voilà c'est voici le résumé en gros
de ce qu'ils ont trouvé
et en gros ils ont repris toute la base
de données de le baron est talent ils
ont vérifié tous les caractères
clarifier tous les caractères ils ont
tout pété répéter comme on dit et au
final ils ont fait retourner l'analyse
après avoir tour vérifier ils ont par
vérifier que l'analyse ils ont
revérifier l'anatomie des spécimens donc
ils sont retournés voir tous les
spécimens que baron avait déjà observé
et en gros ce qu'ils trouvent
et contrairement à ce qu'ils disent là
en fait d'ailleurs ils ont annoncé dans
leur abstract ils ont pris un petit peu
d' avance sur leurs résultats je pense
parce que l'abstract a été envoyé le
ce que vous lisez là en fait ça a été
renvoyé à la hes veepee en début d'année
ça a été envoyée au plus tard en avril
et en fait je pense que ils ont un peu
anticipé leurs résultats en disant qu'
il ne retrouverait pas les ornithos et
dida en réalité la presse pendant la
présentation qu'ils ont fait ils ont bel
et bien retrouvé les ornithos et dida
donc voilà donc à part apparemment ça va
quelque part ça va quelque part cette
histoire dorny tossée l'ida et alors ça
va probablement pas remplacer les
manuels de paléontologie et de et de
biologie tout de suite tout de suite ça
c'est sûr parce que il ya du débat vous
voyez que la même personne peut annoncer
une chose et sont opposés dans un
intervalle de six mois donc mais voilà
le c'est intéressant justement là ça va
être intéressant de voir par exemple ce
que
wieman va retrouver avec ces molécules
avec ces protéines ça ça peut être un ça
va être une des grosses questions qu'on
va lui demander de résoudre la question
des ornithos élida donc donc affaire à
suivre
affaire à suivre mais vous voyez le
débat est en cours et c'est là qu'il a
lieu donc pour tous ceux qui croient que
le système de peer review ving il
s'arrête au moment où l'article est
publié
non pas du tout un le peer review ving
de l'article de baron étals de 2017 il
est encore en cours
ils sont en train de tout vérifier tout
vérifié au moindre détail est un autre
grand débat en cours c'était celui
torosaurus torosaurus est-il un adulte
de tricératops ou tricératops est il
encore un juvénile malgré ses 5 tonnes
voilà eh ben il ya eu il ya eu un
traître est un talk très très
intéressant à ce propos ou en fait c'est
un
c'est un étudiant je crois qu'ils ont
donc il faut savoir que le cette théorie
de torosaurus est un adulte de
tricératops
elle n'a été vérifié que sur les crânes
donc ils ont fait des coupes
histologiques dans les crânes pour voir
si les spécimens étaient adultes
certains spécimens étaient adultes et du
coup ils ont découvert qu' a priori
tricératops eux ils portaient des traces
de de croissance osseuse qui voudraient
dans son crâne qui voudraient indiqué
qu'en gros il n'était pas tout
tricératops n'était pas adulte et du
coup ce qu'ils ont fait en fait c'est
que ils ont voulu faire des coupes
histologiques du coup dans les os longs
c'est à dire dans les humérus les faits
murs etc sauf qu'ils se sont rendus
compte qu'en fait dans la plupart des
cadets les eaux enfin le squelette
n'avait jamais été extrait donc ils ont
fait un travail d enquête qui consistait
à retrouver ou les ceux où les crânes
avaient été découverts pour voir s'il y
avait du squelette avec et ben en fait
ils l'ont easy sont arrivés ils ont
trouvé des squelettes
donc ils ont trouvé des squelettes de
juvéniles très très jeunes de juvéniles
adolescents de juvéniles adultes c'est à
dire de tricératops adultes et 2
torosaurus et en faisant des coupes
histologiques en fait dans les halls ont
ils se sont rendus compte que bah ce
qu'on appelle tricératops adule enfin ce
qu'on appelle tricératops adultes ou
torosaurus juvénile du coup bah en fait
ça a déjà une histologie de haut niveau
des os longs l'histologie indiquent
qu'ils ne grandissait plus donc c'est
vous connaissez l'histoire c'est
l'histoire des cercles des cercles
concentriques comme sur un arbre voilà
chaque année il ya un nouveau cercle dos
de ce qui est déposé
ça fait des cercles de croissance à
l'intérieur de l'os et en fait quand il
coupe les os de tricératops adultes
slash tojo torosaurus juvénile bah en
fait il trouve que c'est pas un tour au
russe juvénile c'est un tricératops
adultes quoi il ya plus de cercles de
croissance les cercles de croissance
s'amenuisent vers la surface jusqu'à ce
qu'on les voit disparaître complètement
donc tricératops apparemment ne
grandissait plus ce qui veut dire que
tricératops et adultes eiaca apparemment
torosaurus est bel et bien une espèce
différente donc là
là pour le coup j'ai pas envie de dire
affaire à suivre parce que j'ai un peu
peur que ça ne cimente le débat
définitivement du moins le débat sera
cimenté quand ce sera publié et
peut-être que jack corner qui était le
lin stig ateurs de la théorie du
torosaurus juvénile répondra je ne sais
pas mais on verra bien mais là j'ai
l'impression que ça va ça va
définitivement mettre un point final au
débat
et puis bah live hippie sais c'est
découvrir les choses qu'on aurait manqué
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas que des choses
nouvelles qui sont présentés à la xviiie
pia des choses anciennes aussi mais des
choses anciennes qui sont des fois passé
sous le radar
donc ça ça arrive très souvent qu'on
voit notamment dans les disciplines qui
sont pas directement liées aux nôtres
voilà il arrive souvent que des choses
soient publiés puis qu'on les voit pas
passer et puis d'un seul coup on va là
on va au meeting de la sv pis on va
avoir les présentations et on se rend
compte que ah bah tiens j'avais raté ça
donc ça c'est intéressant d'un point de
vue recherche c'est aussi intéressant
d'un point de vue enseignements ça
permet de se tenir à jour tout
simplement donc
donc voilà on se renseigne sur les
sujets qui sont à la mode et puis on
et puis surtout la dernière chose eh ben
ça permet de faire des présentations
soi-même et de montrer du coup ce qu'on
a fait ce qu'on a accompli parce que et
c'est ce que tout le monde fait
finalement tout le monde montre ce qu'il
a accompli et cherche à voir un petit
peu parce que la communauté
scientifique en pense donc il ya les
choses qui sont accueillies avec
scepticisme
il ya des choses qui sont accueillies
avec enthousiasme
il ya des choses qui sont accueillis
avec neutralité la neutralité
généralement la réponse la plus répandue
mais voilà ça permet de faire soi même
une présentation de présenter nos
recherches généralement les sélectionne
pour qu'elles soient les plus clinquante
possible parce que justement plus non
plus nos résultats on va dire change les
choses plus on sait qu'ils vont être
accueillies avec scepticisme est du coup
plus on cherche à voir jusqu'à quel
point
en fait jusqu'à quel point ça va être
accueilli avec scepticisme
donc c'est un peu une prise de
température sur ce que les sur ce que
les autres pensent de nos recherches et
ça et comment nos recherches sont
perçues par nos pairs donc c'est aussi
très important d'un point de vue
personnel de présenter là bas tout
simplement pour avoir une idée de ce que
les gens pensent de vous est-ce que les
gens vous prennent pour un charlatan
voilà donc c'est donc il ya un peu de
politique je veux dire il ya évidemment
un petit peu de politiques comme je les
dis on cherche les sujets à la mode
on essaye de se faire des contacts mais
non il n'y a pas de grand complot
mondial du darwinisme qui se déroule
pendant ses meetings et globalement
c'est plutôt détendue donc voilà bah et
puis du coup je vais vous mettre un
petit enregistrements que j'ai fait de
ma propre présentation avec des sous
titres juste pour vous donner une idée
de
2 à quoi ça ressemble une présentation
faite à ce genre de congrès voilà
c'était paléo news merci de l'avoir
suivi donc je vous mets la petite vidéo
de ma présentation juste après le
générique n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
pour ne rien manquer l'ancien à très
bientôt
évidemment les hommes ont dit on au
logis
manière nous amène à vivre sous
alimentation pour yoann david alphand la
manif pacifique faut leur dire dit il ce
passage tout conflit blanchi prof de def
jam in love and his 10,9 annick martin
une mycose isolent leurs dettes à herman
whiskers fraîcheur jusqu'à 110 which
makes me fritter foramen best coast et
le lait
foncière euris claude which is
particularly nouvel event
il nous dira religieux comme si maxime
qu'un tel contexte
because if you to i want you to me ryan
characters de soma nous sommes sous pli
cortex n 10 et religieux la rencontre de
samedi eric aux miss casa lrn à risque
de baisse d'accidents jérôme de fermin
mars asie line de dinosaur bibelots
bijoux made by night the board de
nintendo mais soyons tous deux lacs
calling you need to look 1 heure à cause
de son exploit en finale pour la belle
mine ce vice de forme amène une audi r8
sportif as well in the case in some guys
là qui nous donne vie s'est tassée en
général j inform beatles on l'amène is
actually insu propre demi d'opposition a
solidifié
résumé claude hermann ce week-end style
adresse kim jong-il cause du raisonnable
de nobles give you ne constitue à coup
de réformes qui transforment sortie show
is the key mc est maintenant aussi donné
de fausses dates seulement une double
fonction de confort mise en oeuvre tout
plan bio and you and i want you back hui
possible de l'hôpital ahmida duck and
the black d'y aller et comme seven ways
when you go back
le génie de 56,2 au possible une fois en
8 heures locales vendredi sur la mine
harbin collectif l'école de risquer la
vie nationale unique d'outils de l'outil
pendant 10 15 da par lady of reason that
it was not de came from strikers à plus
fort risque est un risque minime prize
mauvaise pente hac timing michel
unifiant différents whiskers a speech in
little nous aussi nous faut la mina
labat que les richesses touristiques en
prison
le joujou iphone téléc 613 biens volés
chez l'habitant fera mais leurs
homologies le cross final si l'évolution
fiscale note aussi la psychose mossley
de cyclos john n 2 des révolutions dans
l'isf istitute luca sbisa angels
ce drame est survenu un type formidable
sauf en période dite reaches one another
one was made in cauda de fort dix dans x
men johan bollen pantxika 2003 il a dit
albert la once investing salle de danse
[Musique]
notre hôte d'honneur de maximum de maxi
dans le cas d'haïti écrit benoît 1 062
femmes et hommes neuf on his compete
life belgium et son chef de file de
cette grande cheese en deux vagues de
maxime anne canada d'une fine de
l'ordinaire et madame specialized in
fine actionne les deux formats n arrange
pas goes down une conne alten son talent
par correspondance
elle connaît la chine at a time in
titouan de tif de pascal correspondent
soutenir l vers la roumanie indices
cerise sur le cheese
j'estime que si la dce organisé jeudi
sont davantage
formé de neuf ici paris concern
synopsis à gino finding 100 marvel sont
ils résolus
cynapsys les deux pays concentrent en
partie de ta forme de poster leur pass
mutuelle en chine a bondi de 10 ans
terry saute belle interest diego lugano
team form vi dans le monde mac si dans
le canal du world de pink floyd en fois
et comme dit jacques services basiques
les hausses significatives de
morphologie de maxime du canal
tous deux partie de ce milieu des
trawnikis rendu dans son analyse la
place de structures in patria following
sol ibérique aux vérifications
ce fut une belle flambée de
l'institution
une promesse d'un ancien du monde y
compris celle de maxime big apple pas
une fille de st-tite states has de
report d'une inflammation des doubles
d'une forme mutante fram un seul sony
philips we sing it means that he is king
qui n 10 km possible on de la seconde
ancestor courbet de perthus est bon
tirage pour diane jean claude marin
which means that des probables la
touriste gosse likely hypothétique
l'équivalent outre de leurs sentiments
de haine a dit dai ichi exactement le
jean en uniforme italie folle à mina
pour la guinée n'a remis à madoff and
devices de cinq organisations donnent
son rival lui une formidable fois mina n
de maxime le canal sodique le dieu ils
tombèrent dans la file a dit intérieur
roche blanche
il consiste un clic orientés 2,3 le
canada line aux designs just a game of
thrones à la 9e' de madame anne so i can
say to human rights first en floride un
problème de moscou lors de la relâche
des locaux des roses blanches de bluwan
qui flambent dans x men dans notre pays
il consiste un trio candidats de lecture
maximale soutient michel
caractéristiques d'une farine midi exige
un petit incident diplomatique
officielle l'herbe sur vos engines ouvre
la mène tous deux font la paire de
zygomatiques
which i love le camp d'alpha la mer le
gatinois de la crue maximale sous jean
de zygomatiques formelle où il ya un
intérieur mais aussi pour la même
bâtisse d'enquêté mixte de canalisations
l'accueillît homologue east de boston à
ne la ramènent wish 2002 il faut avant
tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]